Berlin the capital of Germany a city
that attracts young people like a magnet
some of them come to party others come
to study management at one of Europe's
most renowned business schools
katti so so let's see hopes to overcome
injustice one day in his home country
Lesotho
Alberto bulletin of Ghana once a career
helping companies get started
Matty Don Blow who comes from Zimbabwe
she's bursting with ideas about what
she'll do after her upcoming graduation
from the European School of Management
and Technology
the last two years spent studying were
quite a strain for Matina she had little
leisure time or recreation but today
she's going to indulge in something
sweet
courses at the ESM tea are held in
English but Matata
also speaks very good German she came to
Germany from Zimbabwe six years ago
a few weeks ago Matina was in Africa on
a visit on the startup bus she and other
SMT students toured West Africa learning
about the region's problems and she's
happy to talk about the trip you work
with a team to develop a business idea
how you started as you do in a design
thinking process identified lots of
problems and then you sort of cut down
cut down funnel down until you you know
identify the one that you'd like to work
on Matias start off idea is to
digitalize educational material and
provide it on an online platform that'll
help make learning more accessible
I was talking to a guy from Liberia
while I was on the venture bus and he
said such a solution would have been so
good during the Ebola outbreak because
if my learning materials are online and
easily accessible I don't need a huge
data internet data package to access it
then it would have made you know
children who couldn't go to school
during the Ebola outbreak might have to
miss out on school on the bus tour
Matias idea met with lots of interest my
point is you can always come up with now
she wants to push the project further
with a business partner in Nigeria
the e SMT offers its first-year students
a course in marketing
katti so so let's see of the suit who
actually studied mathematics at the
European School of Management and
Technology he wants to add management
skills to his repertoire but he's
finding it difficult
while mathematics is governed by
rigorous universal rules and logic
marketing is another kettle of fish it's
unsettling for Katy so using numbers and
computation is not a problem but no
English numbers 2 peak comes from the
analysis which I have no background of
the professor advises him to speak with
the other students as much as possible
Alberto bulleting of Ghana knows her way
around Berlin
but the course at the e SMT leads little
time for sightseeing
twice a week the students do have German
language instruction diverse is out
circles the dodging Essen gun versus
Kirti so so let's see likes to have
privacy when he studies for tests the
next exam is never far away at the ESM t
his home country Lesotho and ways of
solving its problems are always on his
mind
government officials not to be corrupt
and then an even distribution of
resources inside the country I can't
make a change now of maybe try to call
in politics see if I can make a change
we're not to be actually the Prime
Minister but maybe Minister yes and then
try to see if I can make a larger impact
but right now I really want to start
small around my area see if actually
changing lives is something that I can
do a reception at the Kofi Annan
business foundation all the students
who've received its scholarships to
study at the ESM T in Berlin are invited
many of them are from African countries
but there are students here from all
over the world to begin with katti so
stays on the sidelines he is not a great
fan of receptions this kind of
celebration
in the next installment we'll see
whether KATUSA gets into the swing of
things at the reception and Matty dawn
glow who starts the final phase of her
es MT studies with a new project plus
Alberto Boateng gets excited about art